big weather story this week big weather
easing everywhere freezing everywhere
here we've even got the window open
tonight your bank mm a lot of oceanfront
birds in front I've done my best sailing
in Burbank the big weather story this
week much of the u.s. being hit with a
terrible winter storm in some areas of
the Midwest temperatures have dropped as
low as 45 below 45 below now a lot of
reporters are out there covering the
cold weather that's the big thing every
time I turn on the news now these
reporters covering the cold weather so
we sent our own correspondents report on
this brutally cold storm let's talk to
now live from International Falls
Minnesota there is yeah
Kent what's it like out there
Oh kkona it's absolutely freezing out
here I can only describe the weather
conditions as subarctic okay Kent are
you okay you look a little sweaty
actually Oh am I let me just take out
this hood yeah it's much better as I was
saying Kona being out in the storm right
now you're you're risking death trust me
you do not want to be where I am right
now your hot cocoa sir oh thanks and ER
okay
I'm sorry yeah where are you exactly
right now because it looks like you're
just in a very nice hotel room oh it's
actually not that nice I I had a Belgian
waffle this morning and I'm pretty sure
that berries were not organic it's kind
of a nightmare no I expect you to be
outside like every other reporter that's
covering a storm outside
once you stand out there in the freezing
cold come on Condon so weather report
not a suicide mission you have any of
you know bad it is out there no I don't
have any idea that's why you're being
paid a lot of money to go there and tell
us well I'm sorry I understand I
actually did go out earlier and I
managed to capture some great footage of
the storm check it out
the exhausted mothers have March 17 - we
are now back where they started three
months ago ooh pretty powerful stuff no
Kent that was a clip from march of the
Penguins you didn't even bother to edit
out morgan freeman's narration
oh well that's true I would you're right
I apologize that was the wrong footage
here's my real report as you can see
it's a real mess people are trying to
run up their kids and get home safely
hey stop it stop it that's an iconic
clip from The Shining okay okay what
that's my mistake I know but I swear I
went out there earlier and here's my
100% real report from the eye of the
storm brace yourself this is really
terrifying all right Kent you're an
idiot all right stop it I want you to go
outside right now well please Conan
don't send me out there it's so damn
cold five minutes ago I saw a dog break
in half okay I don't care and you have
to all right hey what if I just crack
the window a little hunter I'll take
that crack the window anything okay
fantastic let me just try to get this
open
okay I'm really sorry for the delay
everybody this should just be taken care
of momentarily Kent how are you doing
now Kent
he's dead
why are you applauding he's dead or is
he really good acting all right we'll
take a break
you